quick programming note as the debate
over immigration has risen to the top of
the news in recent weeks a number of
figures on the Left have denounced this
show as racist is notable that not a
single one of them has offered any
evidence to support that slur or even
bothered to rebut the arguments that we
make every night they just make loud
noises about white supremacy and assume
that's an argument of course the rest of
the media dutifully repeat that the
latest person to attack our show as
immoral is former Weekly Standard editor
Bill Kristol now they're an awful lot of
ways we could respond to Krystal former
intellectual who now exists primarily on
Twitter and we considered them but why
Krystal discredited himself
years ago that's what he no longer has a
full-time job so instead we thought it
might be more edifying to restate what
we actually believe about immigration
and you can decide for yourself what you
think of it the point of our immigration
policy the point of all of our policies
is to help Americans watching out for
our citizens is the only reason we have
a government in the first place if
people in other countries enjoy and
benefit from what we do that's great
that's an added bonus and we welcome
that always but it can never be the main
point of what we do Americans are the
main point that's always true no matter
what the issue is when the concerns of
foreigners take precedence over the
needs of Americans our government is
betraying us and has become illegitimate
of course that's exactly what's been
happening voters understand this and
they hate it that's why they elected
Trump to permanent Washington election
results from last year where a hard slap
in the face a rebuke they could not
accept and refuse to learn from so
instead they decided their own country
was irredeemable and its population
should be ignored that's how we wound up
with an immigration policy that most
Americans do not support because the
people making the policy don't care if
you support it or not immigration
clearly has upsides and we try to note
that many immigrants are impressive
people really impressive people and that
greatly to this country we know a lot of
immigrants like that we also know some
who shouldn't be here not all immigrants
are the same just like not all college
applicants are
see some are worth admitting others are
not Americans get to decide who makes
the cut it's our country it's our call
that's the main point we're making maybe
you sincerely believe that importing
millions of poor people from around the
world will make America richer and more
stable and maybe you're right
but before you do that before you import
them you should explain exactly how
that's going to work you're not allowed
to change America profoundly and forever
without showing the rest of us how it's
going to make our lives better that's an
honest question
and you can't avoid it forever simply by
shrieking racist